[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياط في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
هذه اللقطات من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
نتابعها مباشره وفيها نتابع التطورات
المستمره مع استمرار المعارك والمواجهات
وهذه هي صور المباشره من غزه وفيها نتابع
بعد توعد الفصائل الاثر استشهاد الاسير
خضر عدنان واطلاق رشقات صاروخيه وقصف
الاحتلال لبعض المناطق في القطاع
وفي مواضع الحصاد هذه الليله
مع استمرار المواجهات في السودان تركز
الاشتباكات في محيط القصر الرئاسي
بالخرطوم الجيش يواصل طلعاته الجويه في
الخرطوم بحري واندرمان وشرق النيل وقوات
الدعم الساريه تقول انها اسقطت الطائره
ميج تابعه للجيش
بعد تحذير الامم المتحده من ازمه لجوء
كبرى من السودان قد تزعزع استقرار المنطقه
مسؤول الاممي يؤكد ان اكثر من 100 الف شخص
عبروا حدود السودان الى دول الجوار حتى
الان ومنظمه الصحه العالميه تحذر من
تداعيات نقص الخدمات الاساسيه وتفشي
الامراض
هنا على ارض احتجاجا على اعتقاله في سجون
الاحتلال استشهاد الاسير خضر عدنان بعد
اضراب عن الطعام دام سبعه وثمانين يوما
الامم المتحده تطالب اسرائيل بتحقيق شامل
وبعد توعد من الفصائل بالرد اطلاق رشقات
صاروخيه من غزه على مناطق في غلاف القطاع
وقوه الاحتلال تقصف مواقع داخل غزه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد كنا قد
ناقشنا معكم قضيه هذا الرجل عبر منصاتنا
الرقميه طبعا قضيه استشهاد الاسير خضر
عدنان بعد اضراب عن الطعام دائما نحو
ثلاثه اشهر احتجاجا على اعتقاله حيث تفعل
الخبر سريعا الامم المتحده طالبت اسرائيل
بتحقيق وصفته بالشامل في الملابسات بينما
توعدت الفصائل بالرد واعلنت استهداف غلاف
غزه برشقات صاروخيه لترد من جانبها
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه بقصف مواقع في
القطاع استطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي كيف
سينعكس استشهاد الاسير الشيخ خضر عدنان
على قضيه الاعتقال الاداري جاءت نتائج
كالتالي 25% من المصوتين توقعوا تصاعد
حركه الاضراب عن الطعام
بينما توقع تسعه وخمسون في المئه من
المصوتين تصعيد المواجهه مع الاحتلال في
المقابل توقع 16% من المصوتين تراجعا
اسرائيليا عن سياسه الاعتقال الاداريه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم الدخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
اذا ايضا لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا تطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده
ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
البدايه من ومع السودان حيث ما زالت
المعارك متواصله رغم الهدن المعلنه
المعارك تركزت اليوم في الخرطوم في محيط
القصر الرئاسي مره اخرى بينما كان حضور
طائره الجيش لافتا في اكثر من منطقه هذا
اليوم في تفاصيل المشهد على الارض اشتدت
حده المواجهات في العاصمه الخرطوم بين
وحدات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع رغم
الهدنه وافاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع دوي
انفجارات ومعارك في محيط القصر الجمهوري
في العاصمه السودانيه ووصل سلاح الجو
السوداني طلعاته الجويه واستهداف مواقع
للدعم السريع في محاور الخرطوم بحري وام
درمان وشرق النيل
في المقابل ردت قوات الدعم السريع باطلاق
مضاداتها الارضيه باتجاه الطائرات
وقالت قوه الدعم السريع انها اسقطت طائره
من طراز فوق الخرطوم هذا اليوم كما نشاهد
في هذه الصور التمثيليه والتجسيديه لما
قاله الدعم السريع عن اسقاط طائره هذا
اليوم
هذه صور مباشره من العاصمه الخرطوم لاحد
الاحياء وكما يبدو في هذه الساعات من
الليل خاليا من اي حركه اذا سنتابع
مستجدات الوضع في هذه اللحظات في العاصمه
الخرطوم معنا من هناك من جنوبي الخرطوم
مراسل الطاهر المرضي الطاهر ماذا عن هذه
الساعات كما تابعنا بعد يوم ايضا اشتدت
فيه مره اخرى المواجهات بين الطرفين
نعم هذه الساعات الان يسيطر عليها الهدوء
الحذر بعد ان كانت هنالك
اشتباكات وتحليق للطيران الحربي في مواقع
مختلفه وبعد ان كانت هنالك اصوات تسمع في
محيط القصر الرئاسي او في مدينه بحري
وكذلك في مناطق لشرق النيل كانت هذه في
الساعات الفائته ولكن الان هنالك هدوء حذر
في هذه المنطقه
من الحظه بشكل واضح لربما الان الهدنه على
الرغم من الخروقات التي حدثت ولكن تعيش
هذه الخرطوم جنوب لحظات هذه في هدوء كذلك
لاحظنا خلال النهار ان هنالك مساعي من
المواطنين للاستفاده من هذه الهدنه بقدر
المستطاع في التحركات الداخليه لما يختص
باغراضهم واوضاعهم الانسانيه وكذلك
احتياجاتهم الغذائيه الكل هنا يتحدث عن
هدنه يجب ان تكون هذه الهدنه متماسكه حتى
تستطيع ان تؤدي دورها المنوض بها فيما
يختص بالجوانب الانسانيه واسعاف الجرحى
والوصول الى المستشفيات وكذلك
وصول الكوادر الطبيه الى المستشفيات
وسيارات الاسعاف الى غيري وبالاضافه الى
ان تكون هنالك خدمه صحيه في محاوله لاعاده
المستشفيات التي خرجت عن الخدمه في هذه
المناطق وصيانه كذلك الاعطال الكبيره خاصه
نحن في الخرطوم الجنوب نشهد انقطاع للتيار
الكهربائي لمده تزيد عن 24 ساعه ولم يعود
التيار حتى الان هذه ايضا تشكل يعني يعني
معضله اضافيه خاصه وان هذا الامر حدث بعد
اشتداد المعارك كانت بالامس بين الطرفين
لربما ادت الى قصف مواقع تتعلق الكهرباء
او غيرها في هذه الجانب او الاعطال وان
الفرق التي تصل الى هذه المناطق تجد صعوبه
في اصلاح هذا الامر بالاضافه الى ان هنالك
ايضا مشكلات اخرى يعني
تفاقم قضيه الانسانيه بالنسبه للمواطنين
المتعلقه بالسيوله النقديه المصارف مغلقه
تماما والمواطنين الان بدو يعني ينفذ
عندهم تنفذ عندهم النقود التي تعاملون بها
وهم الان يقومون بالترشيد التعامل في هذا
الاطار ومحاوله الحصول على المواد
الغذائيه وكذلك
المتعلقه بالادويه وفتح الصيدليات الجزئي
ايضا يؤرق ولذلك دخول هذه الحرب في
الاسبوع الثالث دون ان تكون هنالك اجراءات
شكرا لتستطيع ان تواكب هذا التطور وهذا
التفاقمي يشكل معضله كبيره بالنسبه
للمواطنين شكرا لك يا طاهر المرضي من جنوب
الخرطوم وقلت بان الوضع هادئ في هذه
اللحظات شكرا لك
في جديد المساعي الديبلوماسيه لانهاء
الصراع المسلح في السودان طالبت الاليه
الثلاثيه بعد اجتماعها الطارئ في اديس
ابابا بوقف الاقتتال السوداني بشكل فوري
كما شددت على اهميه فتح ممرات امنه وتقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه من جانبه كشف محمد
حسن ولد الضباط مدير ديوان رئيس مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي عن خطه للاتحاد من اربع
نقاط اساسيه لحل الازمه السودانيه تم
التفاهم عليها خلال اجتماع الاليه
الثلاثيه واكد ان الحل يجب ان يكون بين
السودانيين والا يفرض عليهم من جهات
خارجيه في هذه الاثناء قالت الولايات
المتحده ان اتصالاتها مستمره مع الطرفين
سعيا لانهاء الصراع ومنع امتداده الى
مناطق اخرى
تحرك ثلاثي بشكل طارئ تلتئم الاليه التي
تضم بعثه الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي
ومنظمه ايجاد يؤكد المجتمعون على اهميه
انهاء الصراع المسلح في السودان وفتح
ممرات انسانيه امنه وحتى يحدث ذلك كله
تتسارع المساعي الاقليميه والدوليه
للتهدئه هذه مبادره من اربع نقاط يطرحها
الاتحاد الافريقي
يجب ان تتوحد المنظومه الدوليه في بوتقه
واحده وهذا ما بدنا نبنيهم ثانيا ان يكون
الحل حل الازمه حل سوداني سوداني بين
السودانيين والا تفرض منظمه ولا قوه مهما
عظمت ارادتها على الشعب السوداني
وثالثا ان ننعم بالازمه السودانيه عن اي
شكل من اشكال التدوين والتدخلات الاجنبيه
واخيرا نؤكد على اننا على رفضنا التام لكل
لجوء الى القوه بعيدا عن منطق القوه تفتح
نافذه امل لحمل طرفي المعضله السودانيه
على الحوار
المبعوث الاممي كشف عن موافقه الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع على ارسال ممثلين
الى محادثات تعقد في السعوديه ويقول فالكر
بيرس ان المفاوضات تهدف الى وقف اطلاق نار
دائم تحت رقابه سودانيه ودوليه في الجوار
العربي الاقرب تحرص مصر كما تقول على
التعامل مع الازمه السودانيه باعتبارها
شانا داخليا لكنها اكدت لضيفها المبعوث
الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده السوداني ضروره
الوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع
والان الاقتتال الخارقه للهدن في السودان
لا يتوقف يسمع الامريكيون هم ايضا صوتهم
ربما بحزم اكبر
سنستمر في اجراء هذه المحادثات فريق الامن
القومي الامريكي على اتصال مباشر مع قياده
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
لحثيهما على انهاء الاعمال العدائيه فورا
ودون شروط كما نتشاور من كثب مع شركاء
الاقليميين وغيرهم منذ مده نحث الجانبين
على الالتزام بشكل كامل بوقف اطلاق النار
وتمديده شحيحه هي المؤشرات الدافعه في ذلك
الاتجاه لكن الاعمال المعقوده على الجهود
المبذوله هنا او هناك لا تنقطع ولا ينقطع
امل السودانيين في ان يعلي المتحاربون من
اخوتهم اخيرا مصلحه بلدهم فوق اي اعتبار
اشير للخبر العاجل على في الشاشه نقله عن
الجيش الاسرائيلي تحديدا ما يجري في قطاع
غزه يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه يقصف الان
اهدافا في قطاع غزه وهذا ايضا ما قاله
مراسل الجزيره بان الطائرات الاسرائيليه
تشن غارات على قطاع غزه وهذه صور مباشره
الان من قطاع غزه في هذه الساعات من الليل
والجيش الاسرائيلي يقول نقصف الان اهدافا
على قطاع غزه في ظل يوم ساخن كان قد سبقه
في الساعات الماضيه ايضا تنفيذ مجموعه من
الفصائل الفلسطينيه ايضا رشقات في غلاف
غزه وفي هذه اللحظات كما يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانه يقصف الان موصفها باهداف
في قطاع غزه
اذا نعود الاشياء ان السوداني واستقبل
ضيفي هنا في الاستوديو اسامه احمد عيدروس
استاذ الدراسات الاستراتيجيه والامنيه
اهلا بك سيد اسامه ايضا يوم اخر اسبوع اخر
وتقريبا نفس روتين المواجهات تقريبا ايضا
نفس المناطق من حيث شده القتال عندما تكلم
عن القصر الجمهوري او
المطار استعمال مكثف هذا اليوم للطائرات
والدعم السريع يقول بانه قد اسقط طائره
كيف تجد هذه المعطيات في ظل الدعوات
والتحرك الدولي الى ان يجلس الطرفان دون
تدخل خارجي بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحياتي
لك وللمشاهديك
ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان تنتهي هذه
الازمه ويحقن الله سبحانه وتعالى دماء
السودانيين
لنعرف ما هو حاصل دعني اقرب لك صوره هذا
الصراع لانه الكلام كثيف جدا وهذا الصراع
يعني دموي بشكل
ومتسارعه فيه الاحداث دعني اتكلم باللغه
اكاديميه
لاقرب هذا
ما حدث لاذهان
المشاهدين بشكل مبسط
في في الحرب عاده كل الجيوش تدافع عن
عمقها الاستراتيجي وهي المناطق الحيويه في
البلد هذه الحرب بدات في العمق
الاستراتيجي للسودان نفسه داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم
الفرق بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع انه عمل الجيش
على امتصاص الصدمه الاولى
وتمت هذه المرحله بنجاح وبعدها تفرق الجيش
لشيئين اولا هو عليه ان يدافع عن العمق
الاستراتيجي الذي هو فيه موجود فيه داخل
العاصمه الاخريه العاصمه الخرطوم لكن قبل
ذلك
عمل جيش باستباق العمق واستباق العمق هي
عمليه تعني تقطيع اطراف كل الامدادات التي
يمكن ان تصل الى العدو او الى الجهه
المقابله في الحرب ونجح الجيش فعلا من بين
18 ولايه سودانيه انتهت الحرب تقريبا او
هدات اصوات الرصاص عندما نتكلم عن العاصمه
سيد اسامه ما هي مؤشرات ما تصفه بالنجاح
هي هي الحرب كانت على كل السودان لم تكن
على العاصمه ودارت معارك شرسه جدا على
المطارات القوات الدعم السريع كانت مركزه
على ان تحرم الجيش من ميزه الطيران وحاولت
استلام المطارات لكن الجيش نجح في انه
تظل كل مطاراته وكل قواعده العسكريه امنه
تقطعت اوصال خطوط الامداد بالنسبه للتمرد
وبهذه الطبقه الجيش عمق
تحركات الدعم السريع ولم يعد هنالك اي
خطوط امداد مفتوحه من من الخارج داخل
العاصمه نفسها فقد طيب
لنعود مره اخرى قطاعي غزه ونشاهد هذه
الصور المباشره لما قلنا قبل قليل بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن بانه ينفذ في هذه
اللحظات عمليات قصف لموصفها باهداف في
قطاع غزه وهذه الصور مباشره نشاهد اذا
نشاهد اذا يبدو انه قصف شديد في
هذا الهدف في قطاع غزه
قصف اخر اذا
تقريبا في نفس المنطقه
من زاويه متابعه الكاميرا في هذه اللحظه
في قطاع غزه طبعا سيكون احاول الاستضاح
الاماكن مع مراسلي الجزيره من قطاع غزه
لهذه العمليه التي يقوم بها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه كما قال طبعا
تبعنا في الساعات الماضيه توصيات من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي للحكومه الاسرائيليه بان
يكون ردها قويا في قطاع غزه على عقب التي
قامت بها الفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
غلاف غزه ونشاهد هذه الصور المباشره لهذا
القصف الشديد لهذه الاهداف في قطاع غزه في
هذه اللحظات التي يقوم فيها الجيش
الاسرائيلي كما قال بما وصفها باهداف
في قطاع غزه سوف نسعى الى استبيان طبيعه
هذه الاهداف في هذه الساعات
وفي هذه الصور المباشره من قطاع غزه نذكر
بالسياق السياسي وربما الذي من خلاله قد
نفهم هذه التطورات وما حدث عقب استشهاد
الشيخ خضر عدنان عقب ايام طويله من اعلانه
لاعلان للعذراء بنعاني الطعام نتيجه
اعتقاله استشهد الشيخ خضر عدنان
وبعد ذلك شاهدنا احتجاجات في الشارع
الفلسطيني مواقف من قبل
الاطياف وفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه خاصه
من حركه الجهاد التي ينتمي لها الشيخ
عدنان خضر شاهدنا عمليات من قبل فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ثم جاءت توصيات من
قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي للحكومه الاسرائيليه
بان يكون الرد قويا على هذه الرقشه
الرشقات في غلاف غ وفي هذه اللحظات نتابع
هذه الصور المباشره من قطاع غزه لتنفيذ
الجيش الاسرائيلي
لعمليات وقصف
لاهداف وغارات اسرائيليه تستهدف عده مواقع
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه شمال وجنوب مدينه غزه
اذا هذا حسب مراسل الجزيره غارات
اسرائيليه تستهدف عده مواقع
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه شمال
وجنوب مدينه غزه يقوم بها الطيران
الاسرائيلي اذا هي غارات اسرائيليه تستهدف
عده مواقع للمقاومه الفلسطينيه شمال وجنوب
مدينه غزه كان هناك حديث عن جهود اقليميه
الان معي مراسل جزيره هشام ساقوت معه ان
نستبين ونستوضح ونتابع هذه الصور المباشره
لهذا القصف العنيف التي تتعرض له هذه
المواقع في قطاع غزه هشام
وايضا في جنوب غرب مدينه غزه هذا القصف
الاسرائيلي استهدف هذه المواقع في البدايه
من طائرات استطلاع اسرائيليه قصفت هذه
المواقع بعدد من الصواريخ وبعد ذلك
استهدفتها الطائرات الحربيه التي تحلق بين
الفينه والاخرى في سماء قطاع غزه طائرات
الاستطلاع لم تغيب عن سماع القطاع طوال
هذا اليوم الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
نفذت هذه الغارات قبل قليل ربما شاهدنا
عبر الكاميرا ونشاهد الان اعمده الدخان
تتصاعد من هذا الموقع الذي
نشاهد عبر الكاميرا
وهذا الموقع يقع في شمال قطاع غزه ايضا
القصف استهدف موقع اخر غرب جنوب غرب مدينه
غزه وهذه المواقع حتى الان هي مواقع تابعه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه هي مواقع تدريب تكون
مخلاه فيها هكذا اوقات متوتره لسيما وان
الاوضاع متوتره منذ صباح هذا اليوم ويشهد
القطاع وجميع انحاء الاراضي الفلسطينيه
توترا شديدا بعد استشهاد الاسير الفلسطيني
القيادي في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي خضر
عدنان القصف الاسرائيلي
ربما يتواصل على القطاع اللاسيمه واننا
نستمع بشكل واضح الى طائرات الاستطلاع
واصوات الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه هذه
المواقع هي مواقع تابعه كما تحدثنا
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه حتى الان
مجمل هذه الغارات حتى الان هي غارات
اسرائيليه على موقعين فقط للمقاومه القصف
الاسرائيلي استهدف هذه المواقع بعدد من
الصواريخ سواء كانت من طائرات استطلاع
اسرائيليه او طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه هذه
الغارات الاسرائيليه تتزامن ايضا مع
استمرار المقاومه الفلسطينيه اطلاق صواريخ
وقد استمعنا الى عده اصوات لاطلاق صواريخ
باتجاه البلدات والمدن الاسرائيليه في
جنوب اسرائيل هذه البلدات التي تتعرض منذ
الصباح الى اطلاق صواريخ من قطاع غزه حيث
اعلنت الغرفه المشتركه لفصائل المقاومه
عصرا هذا اليوم انها قصفت مستوطنات غلاف
غزه برشقات صاروخيه وقالت ان هذا الرد هو
رد اولي على جريمه اغتيال القائد في حركه
الجهد الاسلامي القائد الفلسطيني خبر
عدنان في الوقت الذي نعت فيه هذا الشيخ
ووصفته بانه قائد وطني وقالت ان هذه
الجريمه ستفجر ردود من ابناء الشعب
الفلسطيني في كافه الساحات واماكن
الاشتباك واكدت انها ستبقى وفيه على الرد
لدماء الشهداء وهذا وهذه التضحيات وحذرت
كذلك الغرفه المشتركه وهذا ربما سيكون هو
اللافت في الموضوع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
التمادي في العدوان وارتكاب اي جريمه
وان ارتكاب اي جرائم بحق الشعب الفلسطيني
لا سيما في قطاع غزه لن يبقى دون رد وستظل
المقاومه على اتم الجهوزيه وهذا ربما يؤكد
ان
التصعيد الاسرائيلي اذا زاد عن حده وتعدى
الخطوط الحمراء ربما ان صح القول يمكن ان
نشهد مزيد من التصعيد الاسرائيلي لكن من
المعروف وكما اعتدنا في مرات سابقه فان
الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما يقصف مواقع
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه هذه المواقع كما
ومعروف هي بعيده نوعا ما عن المناطق
الاقتضاض السكاني هي بالقرب من قطاع غزه
قطاع غزه قطاع مقتض بالسكان لكن هناك خطوط
حمراء هي مواقع تقع على حدود هذه البلدات
سواء في شمال قطاع غزه او مدينه غزه هي
مواقع حدوديه تبتعد عن المناطق المقتضه
بالسكان
استمر القصف الاسرائيلي على هذه المناطق
فيمكن ان يكون هذا التصعيد محدودا يمكن ان
يكون هذا التصعيد ينتهي هذه الليله لكن
اذا تعدت اسرائيل هذه الخطوط وقصفت مواقع
في داخل
قطاع غزه نحن نشاهد الان رشقه صاروخيه
جديده اطلقت من شمال قطاع غزه باتجاه
البلدات في جنوب اسرائيل اذا القصف
الاسرائيلي متواصل الطائرات الاستطلاعيه
والحربيه تواصل تحليقها في سماء القطاع
وايضا الرشقات الصاروخيه مستمره منذ عصر
هذا اليوم لن تتوقف الرشقات الصاروخيه
باتجاه بلدات غلاف غزه هذه البلدات التي
تتعرض لهذا لهذه الرشقات الصاروخيه ردا
على اغتيال اسرائيل
للشيخ خضر عدنان القيادي الفلسطيني
والقائد في حركه الجهاد الاسلامي الذي
اضرب عن الطعام
لاكثر من ثمانين يوما وتركته اسرائيل في
السجن دون علاج ودون متابعه واعلن عن
استشهاد صباح اليوم
وبالتالي الرشقات الصاروخيه مستمره من
قطاع غزه ايضا
الغارات الاسرائيليه على القطاع متواصله
هل مازلت هشام تستمع لاصوات الطائرات تحلق
في سماء غزه
نعم بالفعل ربما طائرات الاستطلاع هي من
تحلق ونستطيع سماعها بشكل واضح الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه تحلق بين الفينه
والاخرى تعرضت الاستطلاع هي طائرات معروفه
في قطاع غزه هي طائرات تسمى في غزه باسم
الزنانه وهي طائرات لا تنفك عن التحليق هي
التحليق يومي مستمر على طوال الساعه ترصد
جميع التحركات في قطاع غزه جميع تحركات
المقاومه والتحركات الاعتياديه
للفلسطينيين وهي كذلك بعض هذه الطائرات
مدخره ومحمله بالصواريخ وتطلق الصواريخ
وهي من اطلقت وبدات الغارات على مواقع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الطائرات الحربيه
تاتي في العاده بعد اطلاق طائرات
الاستطلاع صواريخ على المواقع المستهدفه
او الاهداف في قطاع غزه تاتي وتنفذ
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه بعد ذلك
غارات عنيفه وبصواريخ اكبر من تلك التي
تحملها طائرات الاستطلاع تدمر هذه المواقع
هذه المواقع جراء هذا القصف الاسرائيلي
وهي تتعرض للعديد من الغارات على مدار
العام هذا العام والعام الماضي تعرضت
للعديد من الغارات ودمرت بعضها بالكامل
جراء هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه
وبالتالي الطائرات الاستطلاعيه لا تنفك عن
التحليق طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه ايضا تنفذ
بين الفين والاخرى طلعت حربيه وطلعات جويه
باتجاه قطاع غزه وهي تنفذ هذه الطلعات
لقصف
المواقع ومن ثم تعود الى مواقعها لكن خلال
لاسيما خلال الفتره الاخيره وهذا العام
اطلقت كتائب القسام عليها صواريخ ارض جو
وايضا مضادات ارضيه وهذا السلاح باتت
كتائب القسام تستخدمه بشكل دوري
واضافته كما قالت لقواعد الاشتباك وهي
تعمل على محاوله الحد من تحليق الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه في سماء القطاع
وتنفيذ الغارات بسهوله على مواقع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اذا الغارات الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه حتى الان غارتين على موقعين
للمقاومه ابقى معي هشام وشاهد هذه الصور
قبل قليل وتبعناه مباشره ولكن نعود
نشاهدها الان لهذه الغارات التي وهذا
القصف هذه الصور لهذا القصف التي تقوم به
الطائرات الاسرائيليه قبل قليل في مناطق
غربيه خان يونس في قطاع غزه وكذلك شمال
قطاع
غزه وكما ذكر قبل قليل المراسله جزيره
هشام زقوط بان هذه المواقع هي تابعه
لفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهي خارج
التجمعات
السكانيه طبعا مع مراعاه عندما نتكلم عن
خارج التجمعات السكانيه في قطاع غزه لا
تتكلم عن
كثافه سكانيه عاليه في اقليم وفي قطاع غزه
ولكن هذا القصف كما نشاهد في هذه الصور
قبل قليل تم من خلال الطائرات الاسرائيليه
سواء طائرات الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه او
الطائرات الحربيه التي نفذت هذا القصف
لهذه المواقع التابعه لفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ذلك كان ذلك قبل لحظات فقط
وتبعناه بشكل مباشر على شاشه الجزيره اعود
لك هشام وايضا تابع معك كنت تتكلم على ان
مازلت تستمع لاصوات الطائرات الاستطلاع
تحلق في سماء غزه وهذا امر تعود عليه
القطاع وذكرت ايضا انه الى الان ما زال
الوضع ضمن ما يمكن تسميته بقواعد الاشتباك
فصائل المقاومه اطلقت وتطلق صواريخ باتجاه
اهداف محدده وحتى الان الجانب الاسرائيلي
يقصف في مواقع تابعه للمقاومه ذكرت بانها
غالبا تكون ليس فيها افراد من المقاومه
وهي مواقع للتدريب كما ذكرت هشام
بالفعل هذه المواقع هي مواقع للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه تستخدمها هذه الفصائل ربما
نشاهد الان مزيد من الرشقات الصاروخيه من
عده مناطق في شمال وشرق قطع غزه يمكن ان
نشاهد ربما تكون هذه نشاط صواريخ تابعه
الصواريخ نعم
بالفعل هذا الوميض هو ربما تكون هي نوعين
من الصواريخ هذه صواريخ تابعه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه وايضا صواريخ تابعه للقبه
الحديديه التي تطلق هذه الصواريخ هناك
رشقه ايضا من شمال قطاع غزه العديد من
الصواريخ انطلقت من شمال قطاع غزه باتجاه
بلدات الغلاف نستمع الى اصوات انفجارات
صحيح ايضا هي
من القبه الحديديه التي تطلق هذه الصواريخ
باتجاه صواريخ المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي
تنطلق من قطاع غزه باتجاه بلدات الغلاف
حتى الان مدايات اطلاق الصواريخ من
القطاع باتجاه هذه البلدات هي تستهدف
بلدات غلاف غزه وهذه البلدات هي قريبه من
قطاع غزه وتستهدفها المقاومه الفلسطينيه
في العديد من المرات
ردا على الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه المتواصله
سواء استشهاد الشهيد
الاسير الفلسطيني خبر عدنان او قبل ذلك
بسبب جرائم اسرائيليه سواء في القدس او
الضفه الغربيه اذا استمر الحال على هذا
الحال فان التصعيد ما زال محدودا ضمن
قواعد الاشتباك المعروفه وهذه القواعد
ربما رسمت خلال
التصعيدات اخرى التصعيدات سابقه من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي باتجاه قطاع غزه بمعنى
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يقصف مواقع للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه بعيدا نوعا ما عن المدن
المكتظه والمخيمات المكتظه في قطاع غزه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ترد باطلاق صواريخ
باتجاه بلدات غلاف غزه وهذا يعني اذا لم
تتصاعد اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه هذه البلدات
لم تصل الى مدن مثل القدس وتل ابيب كما
حدث في موجات تصعيد سابقه فان الوضع يمكن
ان يبقى
محدودا وهذا التصعيد يمكن ان يبقى محدودا
نستطيع ان نشاهد عدد من الصواريخ الان
ايضا في شرط مدينه غزه صاروخ هذا صاروخ
واحد على الاقل اطلق الان باتجاه جنوب
اسرائيل لنعرف الى اين الى اي مدى صوت
طائره المقاومه الفلسطينيه اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ باتجاه غلاف غزه ام هل سيتعدى
الرد على اغتيال واستشهاد الاسير
الفلسطيني خضر عدنان الى اي مدى سيكون هل
ستكون المقاومه ترد باتجاه بلدات ومدن
ابعد من غلاف غزه وبالتالي تصعيد
الاطلاق الصواريخ الى هذه البلدات حتى
الان نستطيع ان نقول ان الغرفه المشتركه
للفصائل الفلسطينيه اتخذت موقفا واعلنت
بشكل رسمي ومباشر وواضح وصريح بان الغرفه
المشتركه سترد بشكل
جمعي على اغتيال الشهيد خضر عدنان
واطلقت واعلنت عصر هذا اليوم عن اطلاق
رشقات صاروخيه وهي تواصل اطلاق على ما
يبدو حتى الان لا يوجد
اعلان عن هذه الصواريخ التي اطلقت ولكن
الغرفه المشتركه ما دامت اعلنت عصر هذا
اليوم انها هي من اطلقت الرشقه الصاروخيه
فهي بالتاكيد هذه الصواريخ تتبع للغرفه
المشتركه وهي مسؤوله عن اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ سنعرف ربما خلال الساعات
والدقائق القادمه عندما تعلن الغرفه
المشتركه او الفصائل الفلسطينيه عن هذه
الصواريخ الى اي مدى اطلقت
الفصائل الفلسطينيه هذه الصواريخ هذه
الصواريخ تطلق في العاده من مناطق في قطاع
غزه باتجاه بلدات الغلاف ومدن اسرائيليه
مختلفه اذا استمر اطلاق هذه الصواريخ الى
بلدات الغلاف فان حتى الان يمكن القول ان
هذا التصعيد سيبقى محدودا سيبقى في اطار
قواعد الاشتباك اسرائيل تقصف المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الفصائل الفلسطينيه لم تتعدى
بلدات الغلاف اطلقت اليوم صاروخيه اصل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه ايضا
هذه البلدات هناك عده اصابات في اسرائيل
الرد سيكون كما قالت الغرفه المشتركه لن
يكون من قطاع غزه فحسب بل فان قطاع غزه
سيكون جبهه من احدى هذه الجبهات وان جبهات
اخرى ستشارك في الرد على اغتيال الاسير
الفلسطيني والقيادي في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي خطر عدنان حتى الان نستطيع الان
ان نستمع بشكل واضح الى
طلعاتها لفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهذا
الخبر العاجل ايضا نقع المراسل الجزيري
صفارات انذار تدوي في اسديروت المتاخمه
لحدود غزه وكنا قد شاهدنا قبل قليل صور
مباشره
لصواريخ وكذلك لوميض قال مراسل الجزيره
انها ربما ايضا يكون
لصواريخ القبه الحديديه الاسرائيليا
متابعه لهذا التطورات معنا من القدس
مراسله الجزيره نجوان سامري نجوان تابعنا
قبل قليل بيان للجيش يقول طبعا الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول باننا ننفذ في هذه
اللحظات استهدافا او ضربا او قصفا لاهداف
في قطاع غزه
عبد القادر وهذا ما كان متوقع
ا التي اشارت اليها غالبيه
المصادر ونقلتها وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه مباشره بعد جلسه لمشاورات
امنيه عقدها رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
مع كبار قاده الاجهزه الامنيه في اسرائيل
من بينهم وزير الدفاع وايضا رئيس هيئه
اركان الجيش شاهرت هذا اليوم في اعقاب
الوضع المتوتر واطلاق قضاء الصاروخيه من
قطاع غزه باتجاه مستوطنات غلاف وكان منذ
صباح اليوم وايضا
العصر كانت هناك رشقات كثيفه للصواريخ
التي اطلقت من قطاع غزه وقال بيان
لدينه بانه
بلغت عدد القضاء في الرشقه عصر هذا اليوم
ما لا يقل عن 22
صاروخا ووصف من قبل مراقبين اسرائيليين
بانه عدد كبير جدا قياسا
التبادل او الجولات الاخيره التي شهدناها
بين اسرائيل والمقاومه الفلسطينيه في غزه
في الاشهر الاخيره الماضيه وبعد عقد هذه
الجلسه للمشاورات الامنيه كانت كان هناك
مسؤولون اسرائيليون قد تحدثوا عن ان
الوجهه بالنسبه لاسرائيل هي
رد وانه ما عاد يمكنها التغاضي عن اطلاق
هذه الصواريخ دون الرد وكانت هناك دعوات
من العديد ايضا من الوزراء ونواب في
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي سواء كان من الائتلاف
الحاكم ولكن حتى من المعارضه دعت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الى اتخاذ قرار بالرد على
اطلاق هذه الصواريخ من علم وصفوه بتاكل
قوه الردع الاسرائيليه
كان العديد من
انتهت ويجب حاليا تغيير سياسه
سياسه الاحتواء للموقف وانه يجب الرد
وتوجيه ضربه قويه لفصائل الفلسطينيه في
غزه والرد بشكل حازم حتى وان كان الثمن
لذلك هو امتداد الجوله او المعركه
لاكثر من يوم واحد هذا ما صدر هذا اليوم
بعد المجاورات الامنيه التي عقدها نت الان
حسب المؤشرات من الجانب الاسرائيلي هو رد
ضمن ما يمكن وصفه بقواعد الاشتباك لكن
المجال مفتوح للتطور لما هو اخطر
بالفعل عبد القادر لان بالعاده يعني يكون
معك رد ورد محدود في الجولات المحدوده
التي نسميها المواجهه المحدوده بعد اطلاق
عدد من الصواريخ يكون هناك رد محدود من
قبل اسرائيل على مواقع يصفها عاده الجيش
الاسرائيلي بمواقع تابعه للمقاومه ولكن
راينا ان هذه الصواريخ بدات منذ صباح هذا
اليوم وثم تجددت ظهور اليوم باطلاق قذائف
هاون سقطت ايضا بقرب من
السياج الفاصل السياج الامني الفاصل بين
قطاع غزه والمستوطنات الاسرائيليه ومن
شاهدنا
التاليه وكثيفه جدا منها ما اصاب بشكل
مباشر مستوطنه الزيروت في الشمال الشرقي
للحدودت الى اصابات مباشره
الاجانب في قطاع البناء منها اصابه وصفت
بالمت الى الخطيره كانت هناك اصابات طفيفه
بالاضافه الى عده اصابات بحالات هلع في
الموقع وكانت الشرطه قد اعلنت ايضا اشرطه
الاسرائيليه عن اصابات مباشره في مواقع
مختلفه اخرى في مستوطنتين
مختلفتين لكن يتم تحديد الموقع وهذا ربما
اثار ايضا اسئله لدى الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه
بنوع من ربما عدم عمل منظومه القبه
الحديديه الدفاعيه بشكل
كاف او بشكل لصد كافه الصواريخ التي وصلت
الى المناطق الماموله فهو معروف هذه
المنظومه منظومه الدفاعيه لسد الصواريخ
قريبه المدى تعمل بواسطه الاشعه الليزر
لتحديد موقع الصاروخ وتقوم باطلاق صواريخ
مضاده لصد هذه الصواريخ واعتراضها قبل ان
تصل الى المناطق الماموله ولكنها بالعاده
لا تنط
ارجو ارجو ان تبقي معي نجوان ايضا نشاهد
هذه الصور لهذا القصف كما قلنا وتابعنا
قبل قليل من زاويه اخرى لما قال موقع ولا
الاسرائيلي بان الجيش قصف خمس مواقع في
قطاع غزه طبعا لبعض الاصوات
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
طبعا عندما نتكلم عن قسم مواقع خارج
التجمعات السكانيه في قطاع غزه سنتكلم عن
مساله نسبيه عندما نتكلم عن قطاعي غزه
معروف بكثافته واقتضاضه السكري وبالتالي
حتى وان كان القصف خارج التجمعات السكانيه
فانه كما نشاهد في هذه الصور وكانه داخل
هذه التجمعات السكانيه وهو قصف عنيف كما
نشاهد في هذه الصور وهذا ما اسال عنه
ونتابع ايضا جديد الوضع مع هشام زقوط من
قطاع غزه هذه مباشره ايضا هذا قصف اخر
ويبدو قريب جدا ربما تراجع لصاروخ تم
اطلاقه هشام نحن معك
نعم بالفعل عبد القادر هناك تحليق مكثف
الان للطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه هناك
شهود حيان يتحدثون عن الان قصف ربما شاهدت
عبر نشاهد كاميرا قصف اسرائيلي جديد في
شمال قطاع غزه هذا الموقع ربما كان كنت
اتحدث عن نقل شهود عيان عن قصف اسرائيلي
جديد لموقع في شمال القطاع
بالشرق صور مباشره هذا القسم مباشره او
ليس في داخل التجمعات السكانيه لان الصوره
طبعا في الليل ولا نستطيع نشاهد ايضا مره
اخرى
بالفعل قصف جديد من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه التي تحلق بكثافه الان في
سماء القطاع هذا القصف الاسرائيلي
نستمع الى اصوات انفجارات ناجمه عن هذا
القصف الاسرائيلي الذي يتجدد الان على
موقع جديد للمقاومه الفلسطينيه على ما
يبدو في شمال قطاع غزه يمكن تحديد الموقع
بالنظر لكن بعد قليل ربما ستصل سيارات
الدفاع المدني والاسعاف وشهود العيان في
المنطقه يمكن التاكد من طبيعه هذا الموقع
وهذا الهدف الذي تم استهدافه لكن بالنظر
من من الاعلى يمكن القول ان هذا القصف
الاسرائيلي في شمال قطاع غزه اعمده الدخان
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من هذا الموقع شهود
العيان يتحدثون عن موقع جديد للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه في شمال القطاع اسرائيل
بالعاده عبد القادر تستهدف مواقع تتبع
لحركه حماس
وتحملها مسؤوليه ما يجري في قطاع غزه
لاسيما وانها تحكم القطاع بحسب اسرائيل
وهذا يعزز من فرضيه ان جميع ما يستهدف
الان هي مواقع تتبع مقاومه الفلسطينيه
وحتى الان اسرائيل لم تتخطى
قواعد الاشتباك وتقصف مواقع للمقاومه
بعيده نوعا ما عن مدينه غزه يمكن القول ان
قطاع غزه هو كتله خرسانيه كبيره لا يوجد
مكان لا يوجد فيه منازل لا يوجد مكان هو
منطقه فارغه صحراء او اراضي زراعيه فحسب
سوى المناطق الحدوديه القريبه من السياج
الفاصل وبالتالي هناك اضرار بالتاكيد في
هذه المواقع وفي المنازل المحيطه فيها لكن
حتى الان هذه المواقع في شمال قطاع غزه
وفي ايضا في غرب مدينه غزه يمكن القول
انها بعيدا نوعا ما عن التجمع والاكتضاض
في وسط المدن ووسط المخيمات وبالتالي لا
يكون هناك اصابات او شهداء جراء هذا هذه
الغارات وقد اعتدنا من جولات تصعيد كثيره
شنتها اسرائيل على القطاع خلال الاعوام
ماضيه وخلال ايضا هذا العام نحن لا يوجد
عام في قطاع غزه لم تتعرض فيه لم يتعرض
فيها القطاع الى قصف اسرائيل ما بين عنيف
وما بين الجولات تصعيد وما بين جولات
استمرت عده ايام وبين وما بين قصف استمر
فقط لليله واحده ومن ثم انتهت بفعل جهود
الوسطاء نحن نتحدث الان عن ثلاث مواقع تم
استهدافها من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي
الطائرات الحربيه ايضا طائرات الاستطلاع
شاركت في عمليه القصف واطلقت عده صواريخ
باتجاه هذه المواقع مواقع تتبع للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه المقاومه تخلي هذه المواقع في
العاده جراء هذا التوتر الحاصل منذ صباح
هذا اليوم وايضا المقاومه كانت اخلت هذه
المواقع بعد التصريحات الاسرائيليه عن
وجود اغتيالات وعوده الاغتيالات الى قاده
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في القطاع وايضا في
الخارج وبالتالي كانت تاخذ المقاومه
الفلسطينيه حضرها جراء هذه التصريحات
وتاخذها على محمل الجد وبالتالي هذه
المواقع مخلاه من جميع
العناصر الذين يتواجدون في هذه المواقع
وتستخدمها المقاومه الفلسطينيه سواء
للتدريب او لاغراض تتبع لي المقاومه
الفلسطينيه هناك ايضا طائرات الاستطلاع
وطائرات الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
تعرضت لاطلاق مضادات جويه وايضا لصواريخ
ارض جو تحدثت المصادر الاسرائيليه عن
الاطلاق هذه الصواريخ من قطاع غزه باتجاه
الطائرات الحربيه التي تحلق بالتاكيد حتى
تحدث اسرائيل عده مرات عن هذه
الصواريخ التي اطلقتها وتطلقها كتائب
القسام واعلنت عن ذلك في اوقات سابقه حتى
الان كتائب القسام لم تعلن عن اطلاق هذه
الصواريخ مصادر اسرائيليه هي من تتحدث عن
اطلاق هذه الصواريخ باتجاه الطائرات
الحربيه التي تحلق في سماء القطاع وبدنا
نشهد ان هذه الطائرات لا تحلق لفترات
طويله هي تنفذ الغارات الجويه باتجاه هذه
المواقع ومن تنسحب الى قواعدها خوفا من
تعرضها للاصابه وبالتالي حتى الان
بدات بدات بيانات الفصائل الفلسطينيه الان
نتابع في الخبر العاجل كتائب القسام تقول
دفاعاتنا الجويه تتصدى للطيران المغير على
قطاع غزه بصواريخ ارض جو
بالفعل هذا ما كنا نتحدث عنه عبد القادر
انك تائب القسام باتت تستخدم هذا السلاح
الجديد الذي اعلنت عن استخدامه منذ عده
اشهر في مجابهه الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه التي تقصف مواقع للمقاومه
وتستهدف قطاع غزه في عده غارات جويه اعلان
كتائب القسام الان عن وقالت ان الدفاعات
الجويه التابعه للكتائب تتصدى للطيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي المغيره على قطاع غزه
بصواريخ ارض جو وهذا يعني ان
كتائب القسام تواصل استخدام هذا السلاح
واضافته الى قواعد الاشتباك التي باتت
معروفه عند الجميع
رسمت خلال جولات تصعيد عديده في القطاع
حتى الان يمكن القول من جديد ان هذه
القواعد حتى الان لا يمكن كملاحظين
وكمراقبين وكصحفيين ان نقول انها كسرت حتى
الان اسرائيل تستهدف مواقع تتبع للمقاومه
استهدفت ثلاث مواقع في شمال قطاع غزه
وموقعين للمقاومه الفلسطينيه وفي غرب
مدينه غزه موقع اخر في تلك المنطقه وهذه
المواقع هي مواقع مخلاه حتى الان لم تتحدث
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه نحن نستمع الى
اصوات صح انفجارات ربما تكون ناجمه عن
قصف اسرائيلي او حتى اطلاق صواريخ من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه جميع هذه الصواريخ
تحدث انفجارات واصوات انفجارات تشبه اصوات
القصف الاسرائيلي
وحتى الان كما نقول ان قواعد الاشتباك حتى
لم يتجاوزها اي من الاطراف سواء
الفلسطينيه او الاسرائيليه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه اطلقت رشقات صاروخيه
بداتها بعشرين صاروخ اطلقتها باتجاه بلدات
غلاف غزه وسقطت في سيدي روت وارز وبعض
المدن وبلدات الغلاف وبالتالي لم تتعدى
هذه الصواريخ مناطق قريبه من قطاع غزه لم
تتجاوز كذلك اسرائيل في قصفها هذه الليله
الان نشاهد هذه الصور المسجله
لصواريخ المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي اطلقت
في غلاف غزه وهذا الوميض قد يكون لهذه
الصواريخ او للقبه الحديديه الاسرائيليه
اذا هذه صواريخ تم اطلاقها من قبل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه من قطاع غزه على البلدات
الاسرائيليه الواقعه في هذا الغلاف غلاف
اذا هذه الصور تم التقاطها قبل قليل
للعمليات التي قامت بها وتقوم بها ايضا في
هذه اللحظات فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
مقابل ما يقوم به الجيش الاسرائيلي من
عمليات قصف عن طريق الطيران سواء الطائرات
الاستطلاع او الطائرات الحربيه لعده مواقع
في غزه كان هناك بيان قبل قليل من الجانب
الاسرائيلي وايضا نقلا عن موقع ولا
الاسرائيلي بانه تم استهداف خمس مواقع في
قطاع غزه لفصائل المقاومه وتابعنا ايضا
بيانا من كتائب القسام قالت به بان
دفاعاتنا الجويه واجهت الغارات
الاسرائيليه بصواريخ ارض جو هذا ايضا تطور
لافت في هذه العمليه في هذه الصور
المباشره والمسجله ايضا في المقابل لغلاف
غزه طبعا مباشره من قطاع غزه
والمسجله عن في غلاف غزه
صواريخ المقاومه الفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه نعود لك هشام
حديث عن استهداف جديد في شمال قطع غزه
هناك صوت انفجار استمعنا اليه قبل قليل
المصادر المحليه وشهود العيان يتحدثون عن
استهداف موقع جديد في شمال القطاع لم يتم
تحديد بعد في اي منطقه هذا الاستهداف لكن
الطلعات الجويه يمكن الاستماع اليها بشكل
واضح ما بين الفينه والاخرى للطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه كما تحدثنا طائرات
الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه يمكن استماع الى
ازيز هذه الطائرات وصوت هذه الطائرات
المعروفه باسم الزنانه في القطاع اصوات
الانفجارات لا تنفك عن الاستماع بين
الفينه والاخرى طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه
تنفذ بين الفين والاخرى طلعات وتنفذ غارات
جويه على هذه المواقع ما استطعنا الرصد
حتى الان رغم ان اسرائيل تتحدث عن خمس
مواقع
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه تم استهدافها يمكن
القول ان حتى الان هذه الغارات ثلاث مواقع
في شمال قطاع غزه موقعين وايضا في غرب
مدينه غزه موقع اخر لكن ربما اسرائيل
تستهدف مواقع
بجانب هذه المواقع وتكون هذه عدد من
الاراضي الزراعيه وايضا
هشام عن شرق جباليه وعن غرب خان يونس
بالفعل هناك حسب ما رصدنا ربما اسرائيل
ستكون دقيقه في استهداف هذه المواقع لكن
حسب ما رصدنا حتى الان وانت تعرف عبد
القادر ان هديه المواقع المستهدفه لا يمكن
الوصول اليها بسهوله هناك تخوف من عوده
القصف الاسرائيلي اليها وبالتالي تكون
المعلومات شحيحه نوعا ما في هذا الجانب
ومعرفه ما الذي تم استهدافه بالضبط عدد
هذه المواقع بالضبط
هشام ايضا هذه الصور من زاويه اخرى التقطت
من قبل احد المواطنين في قطاع غزه
ترصد لحظات
تنفيذ الجيش الاسرائيلي لهذه الغرض ونستمع
لهذه الاصوات المصاحبه لهذا القصف
[موسيقى]
اذا هذه هي الصور ايضا الملتقطه من احد
سكان قطاع غزه وقبل قليل ايضا شاهدنا صور
ايضا ملتقطه لعائله من داخل منزلها
لتفجير يبدو في الصور من شده التفجير بانه
كان قريبا جدا من موقع التصوير وكما ذكر
قبل قليل مراسل الجزيره في قطاع غزه عباره
عن كتله خرسانيه متواصله وبالتالي حتى وان
نفذ الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليات تستهدف مواقع
للمقاومه فالتداخل السكاني والتجمعات
السكانيه مع هذه المواقع يجعل
التمييز بين المواقع العسكريه المستهدفه
وبين حيث يوجد السكان مساله صعبه للغايه
هشام
نعم بالفعل عبد القادر التمييز بين القصف
وخاصه في ظل صعوبه وصول الطواقب الطبيه
وطواقم الدفاع المدني الى هذه المناطق
خوفا من عوده استهدافها من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه التي تحلق ولا زالت
تحلق بين الفينه والاخرى في سماء القطاع
طائرات الاستطلاع التي تحمل الذخيره
والصواريخ ايضا هي تحلق في سماء القطاع
واستهدفت وهي من تبدا في العاده بقصف هذه
المواقع التابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه على
الاقل ثلاث مواقع للمقاومه استطاع شهود
العين مشاهدتها وتصويرها وراينا هذه الصور
منتشره على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في
غزه نحن نتابع مع شهود العيان وايضا مع
الاجهزه الامنيه والمصادر الامنيه التي
تتحدث عن هذا القصف وتؤكد ان القصف
الاسرائيلي استهدف عده مواقع للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه في غزه
وقالت كذلك اصدرت وزاره الصحه تص الصحفي
قالت ان انها رفعت الجهوزيه في كافه
المستشفيات ووحدات الاسعاف والطوارئ
للتعامل مع تداعيات هذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي
وما زالت طواقم الاسعاف حتى الان ربما في
محيط تلك المناطق المستهدفه خوفا من وجود
اصابات نحن ايضا نشاهد
ايضا ربما اطلاق صاروخ ربما
في هذه الصور المباشره ما هو اطلاق صاروخ
فعلا او قصف اسرائيلي او قصف ربما
اسرائيلي هو باتجاه
في الان فعلا هو قصف اسرائيلي هذه غاره
اسرائيليه نستطيع ان نشاهد قوه هذا القصف
الان هذا القصف اقترب اكثر من تلك الغارات
الاسرائيليه التي شنتها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على المواقع السابقه هذا
القصف ربما يكون في مخيم الشاطئ في غرب
مدينه غزه هذا المخيم المكتظ واحد اهم
المخيمات
احد اهم المخيمات الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه
هناك موقع للمقاومه الفلسطينيه قريب من
هذا المخيم ويبدو ان اسرائيل والجيش
الاسرائيلي استهدف هذا الموقع اذا القصف
يقترب اكثر فاكثر من
المناطق المكتظه والمخيمات المختضه
بالسكان واي منطقه هذا
فعلا هو الغارات الاسرائيليه حتى الان عده
غارات نفذتها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على ذات الموقع وهو الموقع في
غرب مدينه غزه بالقرب من مخيم الشاطئ في
غرب مدينه غزه هذا المخيم الذي يقع في
حدود مدينه غزه هو موقع من اكثر
المخيمات المكتظه بالسكان وهو موقع قريب
من منطقه
مكتظه من مخيم الشاطئ وايضا يحده
كثير من المناطق السكنيه وايضا المناطق
السياحيه في تلك المنطقه استهداف اسرائيل
لهذا الموقع هو بالتاكيد
لا يزال ضمن ربما القول انه لا يزال ضمن
قواعد الاشتباك لكنه اقترب اكثر من
المناطق المكتظه
الى اصوات الطائرات فعلا
لان نزلنا نستمع الى اصوات الطائرات تحلق
في سماء القطاع ايضا سيارات الاسعاف
والدفاع المدني تتوجه الى هذه المناطق
خوفا من وجود اي
اصابات او شهداء جراء هذا القصف
الاسرائيلي لكن كما قلنا فهذه المواقع
تكون مخلاه الاصابات تكون جراء الشظايا
التي
تتناثر في محيط كبير جراء القصف
الاسرائيلي عده صواريخ تستهدف هذه المواقع
جميع المواقع المستهدفه حتى الان اطلقت
عليها طائرات الاستطلاع عده صواريخ وايضا
تبعت ذلك طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه بقصفها
بعدد من الصواريخ ثلاث صواريخ على الاقل
لكل موقع تم استهدافه وهذا ينتج عنه اصوات
انفجارات قويه
وتتناثر الشظايا في مناطق واسعه
[موسيقى]
ايضا بعض المنازل ايضا نتيجه هذا القصف
والتي تكون قريبه من هذا القصف تضررت
وبالتالي احتمال ان يكون هناك بعض من
المدنيين من يتضررون حتى نتيجه
الاهتزاز العنيف نتيجه هذا القصف
بالفعل جميع المناطق المستهدفه هي مناطق
تقع فيها منازل للسكان تصل الاصوات
الاصوات اصوات مرعبه مخيفه لا سيما
للاطفال الذين باتوا يعانون جراء هذه
الغارات الاسرائيليه التي تتواصل على قطاع
غزه وقد شهدنا خلال الاعوام الماضيه عدد
من المؤسسات الحقوقيه ومؤسسات التي تعنى
بالاطفال وتتحدث عن تاثير هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه وهذه الشظائر بالاضافه الى
الاصابات الجسديه هناك اضرار نفسيه تنجم
عن هذه الغارات للا سيما الاطفال والنساء
هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه حتى الان استهدفت
عده مواقع للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
المقاومه كما رصدنا اطلقت عدد من الصواريخ
باتجاه البلدات الاسرائيليه بالتزامن مع
هذا القصف الاسرائيلي وايضا شهدنا اطلاق
واعلان من كتائب القسام الجناح العسكري
لحركه
حماس اعلانها ان اطلقت صواريخ ارض جو
باتجاه
باتجاه الطائرات الحربيه التي تحلق في
سماء القطاع هذه
المضادات التي نشاهد الخبر العاجل
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي طبعا عطفا على ما
ذكرته الان تقول لاذاعه اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانه تم رصد خمس صواريخ اطلقت
من قطاع غزه اذا نذكر بهذا الخبر العاجل
في هذه الساعات عن قيام الجيش الاسرائيلي
واعلاله بتنفيذ عمليات تستهدف مواقع
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه هذه المواقع توزعت
بين مخيم الشاطئ شمال غرب غزه كما تابعنا
قبل قليل في صور مباشره وايضا في شرق
جباليه شمال غرب قطاع غزه وكذلك في خانه
هذه صور مباشره ايضا لقصف اخر يتم في هذه
اللحظه تماما لاحد المواقع ربما مازلنا
نتكلم عن مخيم الشاطئ هشام
بالفعل اصوات انفجارات الان نستمعها من
جديد هذه الانفجارات ربما عدسه الكاميرا
الان تتجه الى شمال القطاع وهذه
الانفجارات ربما تحدث في شمال القطاع التي
ركزت الطائرات الحربيه غاراتها على هذه
المواقع التي تقع في شمال القطاع اخر قصف
اسرائيلي
تحدثنا
وتواصلنا مع شهود العيان هو كان في موقع
في غرب مدينه غزه في مخيم الشاطئ حتى الان
القصف الجديد غير معروف في اي مكان لكنه
يقع في شمال قطاع غزه وهذا الشمال هو بيت
حانون وجباليا وبيت لاهيا وحتى الان غير
معروف طبيعه وموقع الهدف الذي تم استهدافه
في قصف مخيم الشاطئ والموقع الذي يقع في
مخيم الشاطئ هناك شهود عيان يتحدثون عن
اضرار جسيمه حدثت في الموقع في الم
القريبه من هذا الموقع وفي المناطق
السياحيه
والمؤسسات الموجوده في تلك المنطقه شظايا
تناثرت الى مسافات ومدايات ابعد بكثير مما
تناثرت منه المواقع التي استهدفت في شمال
القطاع وايضا في جنوب القطاع نحن نتحدث عن
قارات عنيفه استهدفت عده مواقع القطاع
مجمله في جنوبه وشماله وغربه في عدد من
المناطق تم استهداف هذه المواقع الجيش
الاسرائيلي اذا يواصل غاراته على قطاع غزه
يواصل غاراته على مواقع للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه حتى الان نستطيع القول حتى
الان ان هذه الغارات تستهدف مواقع
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه لم يتم استهداف اي
مناطق مدنيه منازل او اي مناطق قريبه من
السكان سوى تلك الغاره التي موقع في مخيم
الشاطئ وهي الاقرب الى السكان والاقرب الى
مدينه غزه التي تعتبر قلب القطاع والمنطقه
الاكثر اكتظاظ بالسكان والمنطقه المركزيه
كما قلنا
هذه العمليات تاتي بعد استشهاد
المعتقل خضر عدنان بعد اضرابه عن الطعام
لعدد كبير من الايام ثم جاءت بيانات
الفصائل فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي
توعدت بالرد على هذا الاستشهاد
بالفعل عبد القادر الغارات الاسرائيليه
تاتي بعد قصف بعد اغتيال الشهيد الاسير
الفلسطيني القيادي في حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي خطر عدنان الذي كان يضرب عن
الطعام لنحو 90 يوما
واستشهد اليوم في سجنه بعد واتهمت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه اسرائيل باغتياله خاصه ان انها
لم تنقل الاسير خضر عدنان الى المشفى
لتلقي العلاج وبالتالي اعلنت الغرفه
المشتركه للفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهي
تضم كافه الفصائل والاجنحه العسكريه
للفصائل الفلسطينيه اعلنت انها اطلقت
رشقات صاروخيه باتجاه بلدات غلاف غزه وهو
رد موحد على اغتيال واستشهاد الاسير
الفلسطيني القيادي الفلسطيني في حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي خضر عدنان الذي استشهد في
السجن اليوم هناك مصادر عده تحدثت عن
وسطات اقليميه ودولي تحدثت مع الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وهناك محاوله
لتهدئه الاوضاع والوضع حد لهذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي والاكتفاء بهذا الرد الفلسطيني
لاسيما ان الغرفه المشتركه لفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه قالت ان اطلاقها لهذه
الصواريخ هو رد اولي وان جميع الساحات
الفلسطينيه سترد على اغتيال واستشهاد
الاسير الفلسطيني خضر عدنان بالتالي حتى
الان هذه هذا القصف الاسرائيلي يمكن ان
ينجرف الى اوسع من ذلك اذا قصفت اسرائيل
وتجاوزت
القواعد الاشتباك المعروفه واستهدفت مناطق
قريبه من قطاع غزه لكن حتى الان هذا لم
يحدث الصواريخ التي تطلق من قطاع غزه ردا
على اغتيال واستشهاد خبر عدنان هي صواريخ
تسقط في مناطق غلاف غزه
القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف مواقع للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه وهي مواقع مخلاه وحتى الان
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه لم تعلن عن وجود
اي اصابات او شهداء جراء هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي يمكن القول ان حتى
الان هذا التصعيد هو محدود ويمكن احتوائه
اذا تدخل الوسطاء لاحتواء ووقف هذه
الغارات الاسرائيليه على القطاع والتي
تستهدف هذه المواقع هناك يمكن ان نرى في
الشوارع كانت هناك حركه في الشوارع
للسيارات والماره الان تخلو هذه الشوارع
مع هذه الساعه من الماره ولكن لازلنا
نستمع الى اصوات الطائرات لا سيما طائرات
الاستطلاع تحلق في سماء القطع هشام ذكرنا
ببيانات فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه عاقبه
الاعلان عن استشهاد
المعتقل الخضر عدنان
عبد القادر جميع الفصائل الفلسطينيه اصدرت
بيانات
التنعي فيها الشهيد خبر عدنان وهو قيادي
فلسطيني في حركه الجهد الاسلامي وهو قيادي
معروف بدا الاضراب عن الطعام واضرب عن
الطعام على مدار سنوات عده مرات بسبب رفضه
للاعتقال الاداري في السجون الاسرائيليه
واتخذ
واتخذ الاضراب وسيله من اجل الحريه واطلق
سراح عده مرات في بسبب اضرابه عن الطعام
هذه المره من الواضحه ان اسرائيل اتخذت
قرارا وقد حذرت الفصائل الفلسطينيه عده
مرات من هذا القرار الاسرائيلي وقالت ان
استشهاد اي اسير فلسطيني مضرب سيفجر
الاوضاع في المنطقه وسيفجر الاوضاع في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه
واستشهد قدر عدنان في سبيل اصراره ومن اجل
اصراره على الاضراب عن الطعام من اجل
حريته ورفضه لهذا الاعتقال
الاداري الذي تعتقد فيه اسرائيل
الفلسطينيين دون محاكمه ودون اي قرار
اسرائيلي اكيد ابقى معنا سنذهب مره اخرى
الى نجوان سمري من القدس ومعها نتابع
المتابعات الاسرائيليه لهذه العمليات سواء
التي تتم في قطاع غزه وما زالت متواصله او
ما جرى ويجري في غلاف غزه نجوان
نعم بالفعل الجيش الاسرائيلي واصل شان هذه
الغارات
في قطاع غزه
عده مصادر
[موسيقى]
حديث يدور حتى الان عن خمسه
مختلف تم قصفها من قبل
الاسرائيلي في الساعه الاخيره بعد ان تم
الاعلان عن بدء
العمليه بشان غارات لكن حتى الان لم يتم
الاعلان بشكل رسمي سواء كان من القياده
السياسيه الاسرائيليه او القياده العسكريه
او النطق العسكري الاسرائيلي فيما اذا كان
يدور الحديث عن عمليه عسكريه واسعه في غزه
ام انها كما ذكر الزميل هشام ستكون مواجهه
محدوده ضمن قواعد الاشتباك المعروفه
وتكررت في الاشهر الاخيره عده مرات بين
اجانب الاسرائيلي وبين فصائل
في غزه رغم ان هناك محاولات من قبل الجانب
الاسرائيلي لتصوير الحاجه الى رد قوي
وحازم وفي العاده يحاولون بث ايضا عبر
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه العديد من
الاهداف التي يتم قصفها في مثل هذه
الحالات قد تكون هذه بالفعل مواجهه محدوده
وقد يكون القصف فقط ايضا
الاطراف اليمينيه المتطرفه ولكن ايضا
هذه
الافضل من صفوف المعارضه
الاسرائيلي
لغزه والرد على اطلاق الصواريخ سواء كان
من وراء في هذه الحكومه وايضا من نواب في
احزاب الائتلاف واحزاب المعارضه
الكثير قال منهم بانه يجب انهاء ما وصفوه
بسياسه الاحتواء التي تتبعها اسرائيل منذ
فتره ارجو ان تبقي معي نجوى انوي هذه
الصور الاولى
لصواريخ ارض جو التي تكلمت عنها او جاءت
في بيان كتائب القسام التي قال بانه تم
استعمالها صواريخ ارض جو من قبل كتائب
القسائم التي اطلقت في مواجهه الطائرات
الاسرائيليه التي كانت تحلق في سماء قطاع
غزه سواء طائرات الاستطلاع المعروفه
بالزنانه او بالطائرات الحربيه اذا هو
تطور قد يكون لافتا ومهما عسكريه في صعيد
التفاصيل العسكريه في تطور اساليب
الفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه هذه الصور
الاولى
لهذه الصواريخ صواريخ ارض جو التي
استعملتها كتائب القسام هذا اليوم في
مواجهه الطائرات الاحتلال التي كانت تحلق
في سماء قطاع غزه